I've been conducting participant
observation fieldwork with a team of
ethnographers let me see if I think yeah
well the team of ethnographers laurihart
Georg Karen Dino's Fernando Montero
castrillo since the fall of 2007 on a
block in the predominantly Puerto Rican
section of North Philadelphia where both
Fernando and Jorge the two young guys at
the end we're living up until just two
months ago now 47% of the residents in
our in this census track that we're in
have annual incomes below the pop the
poverty line almost twice the citywide
rate of twenty four percent and three
and a half times the national rate of
thirteen and a half percent three of the
census tracts surrounding us have
poverty rates of over fifty four percent
and five of the eight poorest census
tracts in the city are in the Puerto
Rican section of North Philadelphia
they're the the poorest ethnic group in
the city Philadelphia is also the poor
the poorest of the ten largest cities in
the United States and it's lost
residents every single year since 1951
until last year when it ambiguously
gained residents but primarily through
population accrual population in Korea
mean them reproduction biological
reproduction not immigration which is
what you want to gain with so
demographers identified the city as one
of the five hyper segregated metropolis
in the United States and Puerto Ricans
migrated to Philadelphia in large
numbers immediately after World War two
seeking the factory jobs that were
disappearing during the next three
decades as in many u.s. Center cities
beset by indie industrialization and
public and private sector disinvestment
the drug economy filled the economic
vacuum left by the industrialization and
not coincidentally the formerly
industrial core of the city to which
Puerto Rican immigrants had had had
had headed has become the region's
largest open-air drug market for heroin
powder heroin and powder cocaine and
actually this is a picture of crap crack
but but it's primarily heroin and powder
cocaine it serves mainly white primarily
white injectors from other impoverished
Philadelphia neighborhoods and the
tri-state regional suburban sprawl
Pennsylvania New Jersey and Delaware
it's very conveniently located on all
the highways and and also the the public
transportation I know this as I was
saying this is an HIV researcher
audience and I apologize for not giving
a more hardcore HIV talk but what's
happened is I'm in the midst of a long
term HIV prevention study analyzing the
HIV risk environment by trying to set
violence hyper segregation poverty
deindustrialization and that details of
the mechanisms of the zero tolerance war
on drugs and then the effects of hyper
incarceration at the center of the
structuring of that HIV risk environment
so but but because of Leif's prompting
and because I'm actually super
interested in this and I want to take
advantage of what you know to run this
by you it's just it's a hypothesis
really with respect to to this HIV risk
environment I think it's a it's a it's
an especially important city and and
specifically a neighborhood to for
Public Health to study because it's not
entirely bad news from an HIV
perspective it should have absolutely
horrendous and absolutely horrendous HIV
infection rate it it's in this in the
largest u.s. city I mean it's in this
the u.s. the large US cities in the
United States Philadelphia has the
highest HIV rate and the most
heterosexual HIV rate and Philadelphia
specifically has had a long term miss
had a long term a very long term powder
heroin
epidemic but but more specifically it's
had a powder cocaine epidemic that we
don't see as intensely in other cities
and the the what we what we learned from
before crack in in in the early 1980s is
that the the variable that single that
that most closely associate smo sprach
somalia so shi'ites with zero conversion
is HIV is cocaine injection and those of
us that have had that made the mistake
of spending time in cocaine shooting
galleries McCann attest to how
extraordinarily bloody the logistics of
cocaine injection become the the
unfortunate sort of pharmacological the
physiological effective of cocaine is
precisely did to constrict your veins
and also you can't absorb it unless it
goes into your vein when you inject if
you if you miss your vein it just
disintegrates and get some metabolized
metabolize metabolize that without
getting you high so people are
absolutely desperate to get it into
their vein and and and they have to keep
poking as time progresses because the
veins are getting are resisting the
cocaine more and more as a matter fact
you know is it's used in surgery
precisely as a vasoconstrictor to stop
bleeding but the result is extremely
bloody injections and because of the
multiple poking and and when someone's
on a binge they're specifically looking
for I mean they're ready to inject
literally minutes after their last
injection if they have enough money and
if there's cocaine around so it can
become very very chaotic but
surprisingly HIV
Philadelphia doesn't have it has a high
HIV epidemic but but it's not super high
like I expected it to be the way
Vancouver became than the way Montreal
became during their cocaine injections
and I think
that the reason is that the what what
what when I first came I thought it was
sort of an incompetent needle exchange
program it actually works they they they
have a de facto policy of promoting
secondary exchange and people come
literally exchanging suitcase full of
syringes and and as a result there's a
whole sector of injectors whose income
is entirely generated by reselling
needles from the needle exchange and
what that results in is twenty four
hours you know 24/7 there's a person
standing on every single path leading to
every single shooting gallery literally
shouting out works works works and you
can but get them at any hour for fifty
cents a piece and if you if you're
patient enough you can get ten for a
dollar from a wholesaler and that's how
they're supplied so they're they're
they're actually extraordinarily
accessible which is a nice a nice
phenomenon the other thing is that the
Philadelphia has a lot of sort of semi
corrupt buprenorphine doctors and what
that results in is a secondary
distribution of buprenorphine one of the
suboxone which is then hooked on on the
way to all these shooting galleries as
well so that when someone hasn't been
able to get the money mug someone or
whatever it is that however they get the
money instead of having to be pushed to
do something desperate they can buy some
discount buprenorphine and stay without
withdrawal symptoms for you know 24
hours 48 hours even so there's there's
these these sort of accidental
free-market interfaces have actually
been I think very positive because I
can't I just can't understand how it's
possible literally you have miles of
open air this this particular open air
shooting gallery is is literally it's I
don't know if it's a a mile or a mile
and a half long it's the train tracks
leading to the to the to the semi
defunct port
and and it's just it's it's you know
it's full of people and full of needles
all along the train tracks so now what's
the the the the the other interface
that's taking place are two very
high-risk populations which is young
whites who are just entering into the
epidemic who then the the the women
began engaging in in in in the local sex
markets and they're they're rather
inexperienced in this case she doesn't
she can't even hit herself for with her
cocaine and then with older Puerto Rican
injectors who are coming from the region
of America that has the highest HIV rate
in the country because Puerto Rico
itself tragically has had a long even
longer term a powder cocaine epidemic
then than the mainland so you know given
those ingredients I would have expected
a much higher much higher HIV rate so
that's just what I wanted to just throw
out in some sense and now I'm going to
enter into the the more anthro talk so
the let me see where I where I jumped to
here oh yeah
now the other the other dynamic that's
taking place is the the whites that are
entering into the into the epidemic are
coming from the other poor neighborhoods
and they're transitioning from opiate
pills from diverted opiate pills that
that'll become relevant in the second
half of this of this talk and that's
something that's happening on a national
level and and very interestingly the
young African Americans and Puerto
Ricans who are also getting addicted to
to codeine and you know opiate diverted
opiate pills
percocet primarily in the case of
Pennsylvania because that's what's on
the Medicare formulary are not
transitioning for the most part to
injection it's an but but unfortunately
sort of the the hip and cool thing to do
on a Saturday night for hi-c
kids is to take percocets in at least in
Pennsylvania and and they're not they're
not quite aware that it's heroin they
don't realize that it gets you
physically addicted in some sense it's
not they argue with me telling me I
don't know what I'm talking about they
say no no that's more like valium you
know that that's more like dope but yeah
and they the young men the the young
sellers often discover that they're
addicted only after they get her
arrested and enter into withdrawal
because it's the first time that they
haven't had access to a steady supply of
pills so now so now what I'm going to be
talking about then is is that the
multi-million dollar the multi-million
dollar drug market valorizes the
cultural skills knowledge --is of the
streets and ability to mobilize violence
of the most impoverished members of the
inner city but then condemns them to
lives of chronic incarceration in the
context of our state's very aggressive
war on drugs now in a nutshell I'm are
I'm trying and bringing borders concept
of habitus formation across social
fields to bear in this a little bit of
jargon but and you don't have to pay
attention to this part but but to bear
on Marx's concept of primitive
accumulation and reframed fucose bio
power to explain the imposition of high
levels of interpersonal and criminal
violence in this high HIV risk
neighborhood where the state's
intervention is dominated by on the one
hand massive investment in hyper
incarceration and on the other hand a
more recent bio political shift to
managing poverty and civility by
subsidizing diagnosis for pathology that
require pharmaceutical medication and I
developed this paper because I couldn't
I just couldn't wrap my head around why
the unite the us mode of neoliberal
government ality continues to foster so
much so many chronic health diseases so
much in per interpersonal and
institutional violence and
infrastructural destruction I said there
must be something
makes it want to keep doing this on some
level and I think I'll be able to show
that a great deal of capital does get
accumulated through the process of
specifically destroying confining and
disabling bodies and lives much of it a
part of that actually gets gets
channeled and accumulated in the medical
and Big Pharma sectors and that'll be
the the the last part of the of the talk
so on the street then a reputation for
mobilizing violence as as as many of us
have have written militia and a
reputation for mobilizing violence and
rage effectively becomes a form of
cultural capital that translates into
useful social capital through networks
of reciprocity based on kinship
friendship romance and utilitarian
economics in another article I've argued
that this elevated level of personal and
criminal violence is not a deviant act
it's embedded in us in a set of concrete
moral economy logics violence becomes
both a risk and a resource to be managed
intimately through social relations that
require kin and friends to reciprocate
obligations of assisted assisted
violence to protect one another's
reputations and self-respect and
physical security now on most days the
neighborhood feels like a very friendly
place many of our neighbors respond to
the routine boredom that unemployment
and poverty imposed by investing their
energy in warm sociability and in that
process developed friendships as well as
vulnerabilities and obligations for
mutual assistive violence spectacular
incidents of violence consequently
irregularly erupt in the midst of a very
dense sociality within a two-month
period for example during our first
spring there were 15 shootings three of
them fatal within four blocks of our
apartment there are also three stabbings
and eleven more aggravated assaults the
following three Springs have been four
Springs now have been just as violent
and just as spectacular last about two
months ago a 17-year old friend of ours
helped a friend
his stab at 20-year old neighbor 20
times to his death for selling count
just for selling counterfeit $10 packets
of heroin with our block stamp on it
that's our Glock stamp or was a while
back it changes constantly initially we
were tempted to attribute these high
levels of violence primarily to the
instrumental need for control of the
highly profitable but officially
unregulated illegal open-air drug
economy that is so visible immediately
throughout the neighborhood in fact
while meant many killings are indeed
related to the enforcement of
territorial market control to death
disputes many if not most of the
violence is more proximally if you want
explained and experienced by most of the
participants as an assertion of
self-respect or as a momentary
submission to uncontrollable rage when
people discuss fights with us
retrospectively it is often framed with
I blacked out missa gay I went blind I
went crazy I spazzed out my mind went
blank the devil in me came out umm it is
understood as a personality attribute
that's out of their control
yet it explains also their ability to
mobilize violence effectively and it's
also on some level a demand a warning to
you to to to respect them I'll be making
two arguments about how state policies
cultivate rage the first and most
obvious is that our overcrowded prisons
have become a gladiator schools for
violence that trap young men in a
closed-loop confining them to a violent
economy of drugs and crime that and that
first part of my argument I think is on
some level somewhat self-evident so I'll
only provide one brief ethnographic
example to elaborate so that we have
more time to elaborate the second
argument about the shift to two from
welfare to SSI with diet through
diagnosis of violent cognitive
disability and that's been taking place
ever since the the decimation of welfare
in
you know mid to late-1990s okay so I'll
do first the prison part Tito a 21 year
old neighbor that's not Tito serving
eight years in prison for accidentally
shooting his best friend while drunk
recalled to us on the eve of his
sentencing how done Ricardo a fifty year
old a fifty year old neighbor and
reformed ex be short they be short they
is the Puerto Rican word it's a colonial
Puerto Rican word for bigshot from when
the Americans used to come over and and
they still do come over and boss
everyone around and it's it's ingrained
with linguistically he he pinned a
disrespectful young drug seller on the
ground and shot his handgun in the
sidewalk next to the young man's head
while ordering him to leave the block
I'm telling you Tito says in admiration
Don Ricardo's got heart nobody messes
with him Tito recounted this story hit
this story in a prison holding cell
where he was facing his first prison
sentence as an adult he's a short baby
face 20 year old and was groping for
strategies on how to best navigate the
inevitable high-stakes violent conflicts
that are routine to everyday prison life
especially for men of his physical
appearance and so these are these are
filled notes from that that Jorge and
Fernando wrote up from that visit
Tito has scratches and bruises on his
face but walks into the visiting room
smiling when he sees us he exclaims man
am I happy to see you because if you
guys would have come a bit later I would
have been down here I would have come
down here in shackles I got in a fight
today with some bull look he even bit me
he raises his shirt revealing a deep
crimson circular bruise image in the
center of his chest I was in my cell and
this [ __ ] came in and just snuck that
means punched me in the back of the head
and then stood there looking at me like
I wasn't going to do anything but when
he put his hands on me he brought out
the devil it was it was like the devil
just took a hold of me my mind went
blank and I jumped on him and he dropped
it and he dropped his banger that's
homemade ya shank the print and prison
knife and I said oh this bull is really
is trying to stab me up I guess because
I came in there minding my own business
quiet
then they saw me that I was that I was
small people think that they can mess
with me I know if I came in here like a
savage then they wouldn't have thought
that I know it that's what I get for
trying to keep to myself people think
you're a [ __ ] the CEO that's this is
him continuing CEO is the correctional
officer the prison guard lock the cell
and let us fight it out so we didn't get
in trouble but when I saw he had the
Banger the shank the his the enemy who
was fighting against I said don't lock
us in but the CEO did any hell
not all COAS are like that you have to
know who is cool and will let you fight
and who is going to send you to the hole
what's amazing about that is just the
contrary interpretation and this really
literally is a gladiator school so he's
thankful to the CEO for having locked
him into them because the alternative in
our prisons now is solitary confinement
for both of you which is you know a
total bummer so the the the I mean the
situations are really beyond what one
can imagine in terms of how violence
gets forced onto you and how it gets
actually enjoyed in in in grotesque ways
by by some of the guards at least or who
do them the favor of not putting them in
solitary confinement ism as as it as a
gentle alternative okay so this this
unit this is the Philadelphia sprawling
County Jail system and you know what's
really gross this was the original one
right the the Foucault style panopticon
and said I Foucault actually it what it
actually came to he that's this the case
study he studied in madness and
civilization was Philadelphia's jail
it's actually not this one but they
built another one and that that's what
they had then when Philadelphia started
losing population nineteen fifty instead
of investing in
in doing something about losing its
population they then built in response
to that with the industrialization
started building all these other jails
meanwhile Philadelphia lost something
like 600,000 people and and just in
instead of investing in itself invested
in in in this carceral complex it has it
had in 2006 it had the highest per
capita incarceration rate at the county
jail level of any any county in the
country
okay so he goes this unit is crazy man a
lot of people don't know I don't know
what's going on yet with their case
they're stressing they have that
uncertainty they don't know if they're
gonna go home soon or if they aren't
ever going to go home now I might end up
killing this [ __ ] cuz when I get mad I
get mad and I don't really know what I'm
doing I was like that I was like that
out in the street too I would get mad at
any little thing and just lose it go
into a rage but I'm happy with how I've
handled myself in here I'm not gonna lie
though I felt better about the fight I
had so much building up man it felt kind
of good to let it all out
now as sociologists and and
criminologists have have have documented
the explosion of the u.s. carceral
system since 1980 with an over fivefold
increase since since Reagan's election
and and also coincidental with that also
an institutional shift a conscious
institutional shift away from
rehabilitation and to and towards
punishment reduction in in education
services treatment programs and so forth
and in the prison context and most
grotesquely
this massive rise has nothing to do with
the actual you know objective
quote-unquote security of the general
population even as crime goes down and
especially violent crime you have the
the population increasing so it's just
it's taken on a logic completely of its
own without any internal
consistency now so the I think actually
in the sense that that it can be
understood as a as a perverse form of
primitive accumulation because capital
is actually extract extracted or at
least concentrated and moved around in
society from this process but it's done
not by exploiting you know in the
old-fashioned Marxist conception of the
surplus value of the labour force of
those who are incarcerated but rather by
precisely lowering their cultural
capital and expelling them in the long
term from the legal labor market because
mcore Cyprian experiences it augments
your violent capital and it positions
you for an immediate reentry and into
into street crime ex-offenders who often
do strive to break the criminal and
violent cycle find it very difficult
obviously to re-enter the legal label
market upon their release their criminal
record exacerbated by the low skill
level imposed by several years of forced
idleness in a purposefully hostile
prison environment that's the devoid of
rehabilitative programs condemns them
then to chronic unemployment infill in
Pennsylvania to make it easier to keep
people out of the labor force for all
employers puts all your information up
on on a website so anyone that applies
for a job you just punch in do you don't
even you don't need their people you
know you don't need their prison number
just their first name last name and date
of birth is enough and you repeatedly
get stories from people in our
neighborhood who get a job because
sometimes it takes a it takes a while
for them to run these checks so they'll
be working for three to six months nope
you know doing a good job so forth and
then they'll just get fired because of
the official policy of the
the corporation that they're employed
with okay so now for the for the subtler
part then of my argument there's been a
bio political shift in the management of
extreme poverty and that increasingly
mediates access to subsidies through
science through psychiatric diagnosis
and and that diagnosis is easiest to
obtain when one is is when one suffers
from out of control violent rage as my
friends describe it they describe
picking up objects from the desks of
their counselors and throwing throwing
the objects around the room and it'll
say that's just that's what I do and and
and that and that works in contrast to
the obviously brutal right hand of the
state's carceral mismanagement of
poverty
this medical left hand of the state's
management of the inner-city poverty and
unemployment which is spearheaded by
dedicated social workers who are working
overtime really working hard to help
poor people and psychiatrists who are
diagnosing personal rage in an attempt
to convert people who have been who have
become since the reform of welfare the
unworthy poor and convert them instead
into the pathological poor in order to
facilitate access to minimal survival
subsidies through SSI through a
diagnosis of permanent cognitive
disability and this has the side effect
of making them scary violent distressed
individuals into stable patients
relatively stable patients who are also
eligible for valuable pharmaceutical
prescriptions along with their the SSI
check that they receive and especially
well organized in conscientious
physicians urine tests their violent
patients to make sure that they're
actually taking their medications some
of which the ones that some of the
atypical antipsychotics that they get
prescribed to them have the unfortunate
side effect of making someone who takes
it for a long time diabetic and obese
it's an especially preoccupying
unintended negative health
time bomb for the growing number of
children diagnosed in elementary school
sometimes with just simple diagnoses
like AI means simple with with harmless
diagnosis like ADHD are relatively
harmless diagnoses like ADHD and other
psychological disorders who some of them
are prescribed atypical antipsychotics
and forced to take their medications by
their parents lest they lose the Social
Security check that then enables the
parent the family to have a minimal
survival to Risa mirai's then my my
structural argument the diagnosis of
uncontrollable violent rage has become
one of the last means for exerting
citizenship claims on the resources of
the vestigial US welfare state single
when men and women can no longer qualify
for stable welfare payments our Tea
Party governor cancelled all payments to
single men even when they're in rehab
addicted to drugs and so forth on on
August 1st actually unless they're
certified as insane or quadriplegic and
then they can enter into the SSI what's
amazing with SSI is also getting harder
and harder and harder to get which then
pushes more and more people into the
violent insane category so right now if
you have if you're paraplegic with you
know your two legs in your hand but you
can move your your arm they'll only give
you two thirds of a VESA of your SSI
check because they say you could do
something with that other hand to make
money it's it's an absolutely insanely
punitive system and on the other hand a
cognitive diagnosis actually is
something that sticks or that can stick
especially when it's unambiguous because
you come in with scars on your body from
self-mutilation or or in bruises and or
you get arrested in those processes of
beating someone up and have the good
luck of getting shifted to through it
through progressive diversionary
programs from prison into
treatment which is increasingly
occurring as well so now the and then
the you know you're you you get a
diagnosis of bipolar disorder
schizophrenia or when in San Francisco
the the doctors who were more leftist
they diagnosed it as PTSD now I'm gonna
read a field note from it was right in
the beginning of of my fieldwork this
was my first meeting with my downstairs
neighbor our downstairs neighbor Manny
introduces himself somewhat shyly to me
by announcing that he was nicknamed el
Samurai during his youth in Puerto Rico
for his knife fighting skills perhaps
because I fail to express enough
interest in his story he catches my
attention a minute later by blurting out
an unprompted non sequitur he soy
maniacally depressive oh yes
schizophrenic Oh tambien I'm I'm a man
I'm I'm manic and depressive and and
schizophrenic also he then breaks into a
warm smile twists his head awkwardly to
the side and gapes his mouth wide open
with his eyeballs tilted transforming
himself instantaneously into a
convincing caricature of a psychotic
patient the problem is he doesn't quite
stop doing that afterwards the shy
earnestness of Manny's self-revelation
and his simultaneous embrace of being
both an effective knife fighter and a
diagnosed psychiatric patient confuses
me at first in fact it makes me a bit
nervous when he then moves his 360 pound
frame closer to me his eyes beginning to
flit anxiously to the let right and the
left and he tells me that he has a devil
inside him and then with growing anger
resonating in his voice he describes
being tasered by the police a few months
ago while he was sitting on the stoop of
our apartment building smoking a
cigarette the cop rushed me and I held
up my hands to show him I had nothing
and said no English he can't speak
English
knowing less the cop thought I was
selling coke just because I was sitting
in front of my house but I wasn't that
day we had run out so he tasers me in
the neck right on my artery and he does
it again and again hitting me on my
chest - something like 20 times I
crumpled to the ground and they
handcuffed me and that's when they
started beating me with their clubs
pointing to the sidewalk at the bottom
of the steps I'm not a well man I'm sick
I'm schizophrenic and manic-depressive
and I take medications for all of that
so that was crazy what they did he
points to the discolored skin on his
neck from the taser hits his wife
interrupts in English they're supposed
to taser you in fatty areas but they
kept hitting him on his neck arteries he
says it felt like his blood was boiling
from the first hit we have pictures of
Manny afterwards and were suing says she
was raised in the United States she
understands the American Dream and
getting a lawsuit for the rest of your
life and so forth and and but the
trouble is she doesn't have the cultural
capital to be able to fulfill that
American dream
so what the police simply did is what
they always do in these cases of
extraordinary brutality they put
resisting arrest charges on on on Manny
and and they won their case and and he
is now on the run and no longer taking
his medication both men and women have
had a habitus or subjectivity of
sensitive sensitivity to insult and
facility for mobilizing out-of-control
disrespect induced rage imposed on them
I'm arguing to summarize the everyday
emergency of economic interpersonal
chemical and institutional violence in
the u.s. inner city encourages local
residents to hone violent techniques of
the body ranging from aggressive
posturing skillful fisticuffs
dissociative raid rage to pride in
surviving and inflicting severe beatings
and in the case of men courage and
excitements during shootouts now you
know what why would something like this
you know
generate or accumulate capital or
concentrate money the millions of
dollars of of cash that concentrate on
two desolate inner-city corners by
open-air drug markets and that's what's
so bizarre about this neighborhood
you can't imagine a poor looking
neighborhood it's just you know every
other house is destroyed
huge factories sometimes they're there
one or two block blocks large that were
literally Mills that are that are
decaying that the city doesn't have
enough money or doesn't care about
enough to even do you know we're you
know they're the cornices are falling
off and killing people occasionally and
so forth or kinda they're they or they
just spontaneously burn from Kent from
people living them with candles and so
forth and despite that you have just
massive amounts of money a Multi multi
million I mean daily coming in onto a
buck with people running in from from
from the whole region with dollars in
their hand to to bring to you know to
spend those dollars on these drug on
these drug corners so it's I mean you
you literally see the money coming
running in it's like it's like swarms of
people marching in from the subways and
and and and from the you know from where
they've parked their cars and so forth
and also a lot of them then become
homeless as addicts and then they just
mill around in the neighborhood turning
it into a multicultural neighborhood
ironically so that's one obvious part
right of this sort of this dynamic of
primitive accumulation where the drug
industry's profit margins come from you
know as the economists would tell us the
Annelle inelastic demand of addicted of
the addicted bodies of clients and also
I think more importantly the scarcity
effects of zero-tolerance law
enforcement and then of course the
straightforward brutality of wanna be
monopolies drug lords who have no
recourse to state mediation to stabilize
markets peacefully and then these
street-level profits trickle up and out
of the out into the legal economy
primarily to lawyers and parasitical
Carson
services hyper visible street violence
and addiction trigger massive public
resource transfers through taxes to fund
our court systems fund our police forces
are unionized guards they're the second
largest political action corporation in
California the guard Union and then of
course cárcel construction contracts and
then petty stuff that all of this
creates an even larger mass base for
supporting this insane carceral ization
process I know if you saw it the the
Bloomberg one of those finance you know
publications says the most profitable
telephone industry is the carceral
telephone industry which is owned by two
corporations one of which is Goldman
Sachs and they charging incredibly poor
people you know - because it's an
inelastic demand you get fifteen minutes
you know whatever it is once a week and
so forth to make your call and and
people are willing to pay anything and
of course it's that part of it is
privatized psychiatrists and social
workers and big pharma then benefit from
from their expanding SSI and Medicaid
subsidies subsidized market diagnosing
the criminally insane and dispensing
prescriptions diverted pills then
recruit new clients for the narcotics
industry and foster new violent
addiction markets on the street and as I
mentioned earlier this year diverted
opiate oh no I didn't mention this this
year diverted opiate pills were the
single biggest cause of fatal overdoses
in the United States so this is this is
occurring on a on a national level this
isn't something that's that's
Philadelphia specific the utility of the
production of capital extends well
beyond dollars though and and and this
is where it extends into sense it that
is to say it seeps into the common sense
of what becomes desirable in family
friends lovers and
and sadly even in children violence
anchors lumpin eyes subjectivity is
unmoored from long-term stable
reproductive right reproductive options
and repeatedly rejected whenever they
try to make an attempt to become
productive citizens the traditional
unworthy poor are increasingly becoming
disabled sociopaths too in order to gain
legitimacy as a redemption as a
redemption strategy and as I've heard
several people yell over the years don't
mess with me I'm crazy and I got the
papers to prove it so I mean I'll stop
I'll stop there and so we have time for
their talks for questions rather